[Harper] Did Justin Timberlake
really sign— [gasps].
- [Jason Kelce] @#$%!
- [Producer] Ohhh.
- [Harper] Oh, my God.
- Ohhh, #$@$.
- [Travis Kelce] That thing is like pure red.
- I mean, he knocked it out of my hand.
- I think it was very, uh, it was uh, yeah.
- Lefkoe here in Cleveland,
the hometown of Travis Kelce.
He’s holding a fashion show tonight.
I’m hosting, and we’re gonna prank
his older brother, Jason Kelce.
Cuz when Travis is in the building, he’s
wildly unpredictable, unlike the wildly
reliable auto and home insurance of State
Farm, who happen to be sponsoring this
episode tonight.
You see what I did there?
Good.
Let’s go ditch that playbook.
- [Producer] K, Jason’s
on the move, everybody.
- [Travis] Let’s go.
- You can have a seat if you
want to watch the monitors.
- Yeah, I’ll just peek.
- [Lefkoe] Man, I don’t get
nervous, but I am nervous right now.
- [Lefkoe voiceover] We told Jason to
come upstairs because he had to sign some
merchandise before the event.
- [Lefkoe] Super Booowl champ!
You want some wine?
- [Jason] I’ll drink some.
- [Lefkoe] You’ll all take some wine.
- Lefkoe almost just lost it right there.
- [Lefkoe] Thank you.
- [Jason] Thank you.
- You want some wine?
Pfffttt.
He is so clueless.
- [Lefkoe] We actually have, like, a bunch
of, um, things that you need to sign and stuff, like—
- [Jason] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Lefkoe] Just cuz at the
end we’re gonna do an auction.
- [Jason] Yeah.
- [Lefkoe] One of them is a Chiefs jersey
that I’ve had for, like, four months.
And I got like Jerry Rice.
I got Justin Timberlake, Michael Jordan…
- Let’s go Chiefs, baby!
- That was like my thing for the event was
I’ll get all these autographs for the one big thing.
- Let’s do it.
- So I’ll have you do that.
- OK.
- Um, but I, I’m gonna go to the bathroom. I'll be back.
- All right, cool.
- Good f--kin’ meeting you, man.
- Good to meet you, brother.
- Eagles legend Jason Kelce!
- [Laughs]
- [Travis] This could get
really outta control.
- [Whispering] Holy crap!
It’s gonna work.
This is gonna work.
Oh, my God.
- [Travis] Killed it.
- I cannot wait for her to do this.
- This is the money moment.
Here we go.
- [Producer] You gotta
take a look at this thing.
It has—
- Yeah, Sean, tell him who’s on it, Sean.
- He might punch us in the face, dude.
- [Producer] Look at it.
See how many you can name.
- I feel weird even signing something
with Michael Jordan’s signature on it.
- All right, Harper, whenever you see
a good moment or an opening, go for it.
- Do any of you want any wine?
- [Producer] Uh, I’m all right.
- [Harper] No?
OK.
Did Justin Timberlake really sign— [gasps].
- [Jason] @#$%
- [Producer] Ohhh.
- [Harper] Oh, my God.
- #$%#
- [Laughing]
- [Producer] Ohhh.
- [Harper] Did I get you?
- [Producer] Try and get that.
- [Producer] You good?
- [Jason] I’m all right. It's not on me.
- [Producer] Ohhhh.
- [Harper in slow motion] [Gasp] Oh my God.
- She spilled that so perfectly.
- [Laughing]
- [Producer] All right, uhhh.
- [Guest] Isn’t that, like, a special jersey?
- [Harper] He kind of moved, and
it knocked it out of my hand.
- I don’t know if that’s a good look, Jace.
- All right, should we go out there now?
- I think you should go.
I think you should get
there as soon as possible.
- [Lefkoe] All right, let’s do this.
Come on.
[Whispering] He is freaking out.
- [Jason] There is no way that just happened.
- [Travis] Lefkoe, are you good brother?
- No.
This was three months, bro.
- [Travis] What?
- [Lefkoe] I’m never gonna
see Timberlake again.
What ha—did it, like, did you spill?
- It was a mistake.
- [Jason] Yeah, it was just—
- He knocked it out of my hand.
- It—I think it was very,
uh, it was, uh, yeah.
- I mean that thing is like pure…
- [Harper] I mean—
- [Travis] ...red.
- [Jason] It adds to the story. You know, it's...
- Is that what I do when
I’m auctioning it off?
- [Jason] I, I don’t know…
- I go, “Hey!”
- [Jason] Yeah.
- And Jason Kelce’s wine…
- [Travis] He just throws wine on a jersey. #$%&.
Did you even sign it yet?
- Huh?
No, I haven’t signed it yet.
- I didn’t get the chance to.
I’ll find a...marker.
- [Travis] Yeah, I mean,
that’ll just make it all better.
- [Harper] I am so sorry.
- [Travis] Uh, thanks for, um, I mean
this—that was literally the entire auction right there.
- I wish we had other stuff on
hand to help, like, clean this up.
- [Travis] That was
literally the entire auction.
You ruined it.
- [Lefkoe] I mean...all right, Jason.
Will you sign it, though?
- [Jason] Yeah, of course.
- [Lefkoe] I don’t know
where you’re gonna sign.
- [Jason] Yeah, I mean, it’s gonna run.
There’s like this one…
- [Travis] Let’s just throw
wine on, on everything.
We’ll throw wine on—
- [Lefkoe] It’s officially
a home Chiefs jersey.
- [Travis] It’s a wine...
Yeah, get the white spot.
- Real nice of you.
The one thing we’re havin’ everyone
do is to write "IGP" underneath.
- [Jason] IGP?
- [Lefkoe] Yeah.
- [Jason] Why IGP?
- Uh, cuz on the show “Ditch the
Playbook” it stands for “I got pranked.”
- #$%* I knew this was happening!
- [Laughing]
- I knew it!
I knew this was happening!
- [Laughing]
As soon as she’s like—
- [Travis] You literally ran outta here,
“I got pranked!
I got pranked!”
- [Lefkoe] Dude, you handled—
- [Jason] No way that
absolutely just happened.
- [Laughing]
- [Lefkoe] All right. You gotta keep writing it—
- [Travis] IGP, IGP.
- [Lefkoe] IGP, IGP.
- [Travis] This is the story.
- [Lefkoe] Oh, that’s amazing.
- [Jason] I’ve never felt…I was—and
then she was, like, saying I did it.
And I was—
- [Lefkoe] I was waiting for you—
- [Jason] I, I did not want to throw her under the bus.
And I feel so bad…
- [Travis] He’s a good guy.
He’s a good guy.
- [Lefkoe] That how good of a teammate he is.
- I was ready to buy it for, like, $2,000.
- [Laughing]
- I was like, “I’m just
gonna buy this auction item!”
- [Lefkoe] All right, come here.
I want you to see what we were
doing back—oh, by the way…
- Thank you so much.
I was—like, I was expecting you to be so mad.
You were like, “Yeah, I did it.
- [Lefkoe] You said he
knocked it out, though.
You, like, ate that.
Come here and check this out.
- Thank you for being such a good sport.
- [Lefkoe] This is what we
had over here the entire time.
- [Jason] Oh, my gosh!
- We had the whole control room over here.
- [Jason] Oh, this is…
This is awesome.
- Watching you, man.
- [Jason] Good job, guys.
That was really well done.
- [Producer] You’re such a good sport.
- [Lefkoe] I love that you
said you were gonna buy it.
- Yeah.
If I was—I was like, dude,
I’m, I’m not gonna rat her out.
I’m just gonna end up spending
two to three grand on this jersey.
- [Travis] I can’t wait for you to see your
face after, like as soon as that happened,
you got up like— [gasps]
- [Laughing]
- [Jason] Oh, my gosh.